Welcome, this is the
end of our second week
here at the Largo Theater
and it's really nice, wonderful
to be out of the house
and working in a safe, open environment.
Let me tell you something very quickly
about the Largo Theater.
There's a lot of strange stuff in here.
It's a very popular comedy theater,
all the great comics perform here
and there's lots of
weird mementos backstage,
and I've spent a lot of time
here and I keep seeing this.
It's a pillow, a pillow
that's crocheted to look like.
I don't know if you can
see this, Sarah Silverman
and this is something I look
at a hundred times a day
while I'm here at the theater
and I have to say, I know
Sarah well, love her,
she's fantastic, very beautiful woman.
This pillow doesn't really do her justice.
I don't think this is an
accurate representation
of Sarah Silverman
and so what I'm going to do
before I leave this theater,
when it's time for us to move on,
is I'm going to have, I swear,
a better, more beautiful,
less dirty and musty Sarah
Silverman, pillow made
and that's my promise to America.